everybody wearing number 42 to honor the
great jackie robinson on both teams in
both games on this day
seventh start of the season he's faced
with twins 19 times in his career
7-6 lifetime record with the 486 era
he was way better last time shep and it
was all because he was able to command
his change up we'll see how he
implements that in today's game here so
two outs the twins let's see if they can
capitalize here with gonzales swinging a
miss big bending curveball and gonzalez
strikes out and that is a good first
inning for matthew boydy through all
four pitches randy dobnick his seventh
start of the year twelfth overall start
in the big leagues is all here's miguel
cabrera
who as we mentioned just one hit away
from tying the great charlie garringer
50 in major league history in hits grab
ball to short polanco from the grass and
left will now throw from the infield
dirt and that is out number three so the
twins with a new look defensively and
cabrera grounds out as dobneck sees the
minimum back-to-back hits for the tigers
to start the second dobneck is going to
try to get into that ground ball double
play mode here the ground ball the short
twins have a chance polanco's second for
juan vargas his return is in time and
there's a double play candelario takes
third but that's exactly
what dobneck and avila danny were
playing for right there now runner third
two down and here's kristen stewart and
now kristen stewart just two for his
last 25. swinging a fly ball left field
fairly deep rosario turned one more than
the other he jumps up it's off his glove
to the base of the wall into score comes
candelario and down to second goes
kristen stewart boy that ball had a lot
of carry might have gotten a boost from
the wind one nothing tigers here in the
second yeah that was just smart hitting
i think you know i think he was looking
for that pitch you know he set his
sights on one certain pitch didn't think
about the slider thought about the
sinker going the other way and he
absolutely buggy with that baby kepler
third banks top of the order here is
polanco into right field and that should
do it
right fielder fielding it he's going to
come up throwing kepler can run a little
bit we're tied up 1-1 on this back fly
by polanco his 15th ruby of the year
runners at the corners with nobody out
here in the third jonathan scope scope
it into a double play his first time up
swinging a little pop fly and that's
going to drop over the head of cino onto
the outfield grass how about it castro
into score tigers take a 2-1 lead two
infield bleeders and now a little soft
pop
just landed on the outfield grass behind
the infield dirt over the head of cino
to give the tigers a lead ladies and
gentlemen boys and girls it's the tigers
day so just what dan said he hit that
ball right off the trademark and that's
not even a blinder and that was just a
little baby pop-up lead off man has been
on now in all four innings and the last
two innings that laid off man has scored
jacoby jones stands in fly ball center
field deep on the run kepler and that
ball is off his glove to the base of the
wall to left field goodroom was all the
way to second base he'll make it to
third jacoby jones will cruise into
second he crashed it to deepest left
center kepler was tracking it he's a
very good defender but it went off his
glove and the tigers have runners at
second and third good swing for jacoby
nobody out for christian stewart fly
ball right center field deep playable
for gonzalez he'll make the catch on the
warning track by the 365 marker driving
home is good over to third goes jones
good situational hitting for christian
stewart his second rbi of the day he
moves up and austin romine against a
drawn in infield singles right back up
the box tigers extend the lead to three
it's now 4-1 detroit put the ball in
play you have a chance and because you
force them to bring the infield in they
have to cut off the runs the lanes are
opened up there's an rbi single for
austin candelario at third good room at
second jones at first that's good speed
on the base pass 4-1 tigers and a big
opportunity to break this game wide open
bay's head down the left field line
candelario is in round and third
is going to interfere
with nico
manny gonzalez is all over that and he
immediately calls interference
you put it in motion you'll see that he
gets something in the way
you see how he kind of gets in the way
and nico has to kind of stop and get out
of the way third base umpire tigers have
scored now in each of the last four
innings two out six one tigers nelson
cruz over two fly ball center field deep
jones going back still going on the
grass on the track at the wall that's
going home run nelson cruz slightly left
of dead center field 437 feet the
distance that's his 12th
and the twins are down by four to six
two games six two tigers and a chance to
add on here in the sixth inning swinging
a fly ball center field deep going back
kepler on the run and that's over his
head one hop up against the wall that's
going to score two castro is home reyes
is home miguel cabrera two run double
eight two tigers here in the sixth
inning miguel cabrera
joins charlie garringer in the top 50
all time in career hits it's uh really
impressive joining that guy right there
tiger great
two outs base is empty in the seventh
swung on and foul tipped into the glove
of boston romaine nico goodrim and
company win game one of the doubleheader